you might outwork me for 30 days or 60
days or 90 days but you ain't gonna beat
me over a year
you can outwork me over two years you
are gonna outwork me over three years
I'm gonna get you eventually I'm a
dripping dam faucet I just keep coming
at you great entrepreneurs are
constantly conscious of selling the
dream to their employees to their
clients to their vendors most people
underestimate what total obsessive
laser-focused really is and what it
looks like the motivation was the top
ten with belief nation
he's ed my let and here's my take on his
top ten roots a success vol 8 enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one sell the dream she great leaders
always sell the dream leaders must have
vision because of your position just by
being a position of a leader you were in
front of everybody aren't you which
means your point of view should be
different you can see things they can't
see your job as a leaders to say here's
what I see this is how amazing it is and
this is how we're going to get there so
great leaders like that book said sell
the dream constantly great entrepreneur
constantly conscious of selling the
dream to their employees to their
clients to their vendors to potential
clients to people they sell to people
they do business with two people in the
warehouse no matter what your business
is I don't care what it is always be
selling the dream listen to me always be
selling the dream it do it repetitiously
don't get tired of saying the same
things over and over again see business
is not about saying new things to old
people business about saying old things
to new people so constantly be selling
the dream rule number two
be relentless people quittin chargebacks
flunking the exam it's all gonna happen
just get ready if you're an entrepreneur
and you want to do something great
you're gonna have false start after
false start false start after false
start get it go and then you don't get
it going then you dump your group grows
then it shrinks I'm telling you right
now just know that I'm gonna make some
money then you're not being an
entrepreneur tons of false starts tons
of setbacks but see a guy like me I knew
someone was better than me there's more
talented people than me
probably more talented than you but like
my dad said the best ability is
availability you might outwork me for 30
days or 60 days or 90 days but you ain't
gonna beat me over a year you can
outwork me over two years you are gonna
outwork me over three years i'ma get you
eventually I'm a dripping damned faucet
I just keep coming at you just like you
could be right
just like you think I just keep coming
you might think I'm not that I just keep
coming I'm too damn tough to give up
most people half-ass half their life all
the time
I knew they're gonna get tired they were
gonna flinch they were to get down they
may not quit the Matsuda letter resume
quit getting why'd they quit recruiting
people they quit and proven themselves
they start sleeping in they spend all
their damn money I'm not gonna do that
something will save money imma get up
early I'm gonna keep getting wide imma
stay relentless just like you should
don't give in to that stuff don't give
in to the fears don't give in to the
setbacks you're gonna have failure it's
part of the game rule number three debt
laser-focused one of the things that
human beings underestimate dramatically
is their capacity to get great at
something if they're totally immersed in
it totally laser focused on something
but as I've coached the very high-end
athletes in my life the top
businesspeople and entertainers I can
tell you that most people underestimate
what total obsessive laser-focused
really is and what it looks like because
you are way more powerful than you know
you are if you went crazy psycho
obsessed laser focused on anything even
something you're totally ill-prepared
for humans have an unreal capacity to
get great at things even if they're not
a natural talent for it if they're
immersed in it and to learn something
and acquire a ton of knowledge in a
short period of time as well society is
conspiring all the time in our culture
to completely distract you so you never
win to just divert your focus and
attention look over here look at this
shiny thing look at this TV show look at
this sports team worried about what's
going on here in this war and they get
these different things on television and
our phones and in our lives and just get
us distracted so we never get obsessed
we never get laser focused for an
extended period of time rule number four
choose the life that you want you get to
choose your life you get to choose how
you feel not other people there's these
illusions in life we really can't
control anything other than our own
thoughts our own behavior our own
patterns we can't control what other
people do say or think
and it's this illusion of control often
times that we can somehow manipulate
other people or manipulate situations
that cause us to fall into these
patterns but what we do have the power
of in life as we have the power to
choose and I say this to you because I'm
somebody just like you I struggle with
the different patterns I have some of
them serve me some of them don't
I sometimes engage in thoughts that
don't create the right emotions for me
that don't serve me I know what it's
like to be frustrated and angry and
depressed and down and lost and fearful
and worried worries a big one for me I
love to fall into the pattern of worry
when certain circumstances begin to
happen it creates a trigger and a
pattern in me a man do I love to worry
and so I give you these tools and
resources because these are things I to
struggle with I've been able to overcome
them by just being aware and choosing
and so the first thing is the power of
choice finish this sentence for me I
choose to be blissful rather than blank
I choose to be blissful rather than
blank what would your answer be one of
the emotions I challenge you to
experience more of in life is bliss you
know we are the calibration of maybe the
five emotions we experience on a regular
basis and so if you're experiencing
depression frustration worry fear
anxiety pain on a regular basis you're
gonna have one life if you're
experiencing bliss and fulfilment and
ecstasy and joy and in your life and
contribution recognition and
significance if you're experiencing love
experience those emotions you have a
totally different life we have the power
to choose which emotions we want to
experience also if you want to learn how
to have more confidence check of my 250
for confidence series it's free the link
to join is in the description below the
minute you begin to get external in your
life worrying about what other people
think about you right you vote you've
lost all control you and it never fills
you up rule number five leverage
problems to grow there's nothing wrong
with making mistakes there's nothing
wrong with even having problems there's
a challenge if we continue to repeat the
same mistake that causes the same
problems and so what can I learn from
this now your leverage
this problem to grow now this isn't
something you're just overcoming and
putting behind you but you're using this
experience in this challenge to move in
front of it not just get it behind you
there's a big difference in that
perspective what's great about this
problem that's a difficult question to
ask when you're going through the middle
of it ed no it's not not if you build
the habit not if you begin to think like
this because what that does is it
changes the meaning to you it puts you
in an empowering state and not a
disempowering state rule number six get
hungry and obsessed you've got to get
hungry and you've got to get focused and
I know they sound like basic things but
go to any area of your life you want
something right now pick the number one
thing you want to change body money
business relationship faith I don't care
what it is pick it right now one to ten
how hungry are you how desperate are you
one to ten the most desperate and hungry
you could be ranked yourself number two
how lazor crazy obsessed focused are you
on what it is you want one to ten ten
being hyper psycho crazy obsessed focus
nothing's in your way and to the extent
you can increase your desperation and
hunger and your obsessive focus will be
to the extent that you can flourish
because when those things convene and
converge all of a sudden the
collaborations the people the
circumstances the breakthroughs the
insights necessary begin to reveal
themselves to you and not only that
reveal themselves to you with momentum
and speed at which you cannot believe
you can wake up a year and a half later
be number one in the world it's
something that you didn't even know
existed before I'm a testimony to that
and you can be as well your success is
going to be predicated more than
anything on your hunger and desperation
level and your ability to get laser
focus and eliminate the distractions in
your life this is what makes us great
rule number seven recognize others
always be recognizing people always be
holding people up always acknowledge
people that are performing at a high
level building
where you're recognizing people all the
time so that people want to rise up you
know if you have an environment of
recognition all the time that the people
who aren't being recognized see the ones
who are and want that to happen so
recognition elevates the company
elevates your vendors elevates your
clients by the way what do you do to
recognize your clients what do you do in
your business to recognize your clients
what do you do to recognize your
recruits what do you do to recognize
your employees we need you to recognize
your vendors what do you do to recognize
your assistant what do you do to
recognize people how great are you at
recognizing people well number eight
learn to listen and one of the things
we've not covered that is such a
critical part of communication and maybe
more important even what you say is your
ability to listen to people it's a huge
part of communication you know I've
taught you before that people don't
respond to what they hear or see they
respond to how they feel when they
interact with you and one of the best
ways to make somebody feel good is that
they feel listened to and that they feel
heard I think being a great listener has
lots of benefits one people will like
you more - you're going to learn more 3
it takes the pressure off you and so
listening skills are so critical rule
number nine believing you're worth
whatever it is good bad or indifferent
in your life your current level of
happiness of joy of success of
fulfilment is exactly what you think you
deserve it's exactly what you think
you're worth it's a hard thing to accept
but in our lives we are getting out of
our life right now exactly what we
believed were worthy of exactly what we
think we deserve our life is a direct
reflection of our identity which is the
thoughts concepts beliefs values and
worth we hold true to be about ourselves
and so as hard as it is to accept we're
getting out of life right now what we
believe we're worth and we believe we're
worth it because of these patterns and
our identity and our lack of choosing to
have what we want not just the material
things not just the body fat not just
the body weight not just the amount of
money not just having the relationship
but choosing the emotion we want and
rule number 10 the last one before our
very special bonus clip is tell great
stories
my dad's a tough dude
a hockey player when I was a little boy
I was little Eddie I'm Eddie the third
by the way my grandfather's Edward my
dad's Edward I'm ever since I was little
Eddie Eddie the third kids at school
called me Eddie spaghetti that wasn't
fun say Eddie spaghetti your meatballs
are ready that's they would say that's
not they teased me and the the jerk that
started this lived right next door to me
little ray-ray this little punk so
there's little Eddie in there's ray-ray
why is he Ray Ray cuz his dad's big Greg
[Music]
we lived in Weymouth Massachusetts at
the time their wound but they wouldn't
want to retire there let's put it that
way
that is not Laguna Beach is it everybody
so my house my house is the same exact
house is Ray race except you know how
track houses I just flip them so it's
his house my house in Reverse so we
shared a driveway their porch there's
stairs to their house was here mine was
there so when they're eating dinner I
can hear all their conversations they
could hear all ours and Ray Ray's the
one who started Eddie spaghetti your
meatballs already and I didn't like it
it needs to kind of mess with me he's
figured out I was kind of soft you know
you kind of figure it out like we're
playing football on the street he kind
of whacked mean I wouldn't whack him
back you know those kind of things
little kids do to figure it out he was
the stud I was the weak kid he figured
it out he was big I was little Eddie
literally little Eddie really small and
so rare I used to kind of slap me around
a little bit and one day we got a little
strafe behind the cars in the driveway
and Ray Ray kicked my ass pretty good
pretty damn good to the point where I
ran away from him crying maybe you can
relate to this and I ran into the house
and my mom was on push oh my gosh he
punched me in the face
oh come here sweetheart I remember come
here baby we're in the kitchen and she's
hugging me it's okay he's a bad boy his
daddy's been in jail like three times
we're just we're not that kind of family
they're mean he's a
and I can hear I can hear here comes Big
Ed down the hallway I can hear him I'm
thinking he's gonna give me a big hug to
write my digs what the hell's going on
in here okay my mom turns around and
says this criminal next door rayray has
assaulted our son for the 400th time
that's what's going on here
are you gonna do anything about this and
my dad goes get your hands off him
because get over here and he gets down
at my level he goes look at me you are
leaving this house and you were going
back over there and you are kicking his
ass you understand me no dad he always I
said you don't come back in this house
until you kick his ass you understand me
my mom and what are you doing Debbie
stop it I know what I'm doing here don't
come back here until you beat him up you
understand me huh oh okay daddy and I
walk out of the door and I walk over to
their porch which is like three steps
from us
and my dad's hid behind the screen I see
him in the kitchen behind our screen
with my mom my mom's crying my dad's
like I got this right and I knocked on
the door there screen that big ray all
tatted up no shirt on he's through the
street what's up Eddie he said um big
ray my dad says I had to come over here
and kick ray Ray's ass or I can't come
home for dinner
so in beer a goes I like that kind of
party let's get it I'm serious I hear
I'm at the door right right right right
that's all yeah right right get over
here little rag little Bulldog comes
running up oh right
hey goes hey Billy Eddie wants another
piece
ray ray goes let's do this I'm like oh
wow we're walking down his stairs and I
could see my dad in the screen over here
I'm like oh my god
and I'll never forget this the two cars
were there my dad's Datsun b210 orange
hash back and his dad's green Pinto
flanked our states right there in the
driveway oil all over the driveway cuz
big ray would change everything in the
driveway and we got up there and big ray
goes you get there you get there go and
Ray Ray came at me and buy some force of
shear blessing from God I got this
little dude in a headlock and I'm giving
him my daddy's to give me noogies
remember Nikki's slightly not to hit him
but I'm looking in the hell out of this
kid's head just like I'm ripping the
hair off his damn head and I'm choking
them noogies I'm trying to look it back
to the screen see my dad I got him dad I
got him dad and so finally I'm newgy in
this kid to death literally can't
breathe and so finally raised Oh get
away get away I'm here I'll get him
right but I won't let him go he's trying
to squirm and I'm gonna slap with him in
the head these little boys out there
right and so finally I kicked his ass
right yeah
so big race tops it being a pulls this
off he's gonna go see ray ready he got
you let's shake his hand then we shook
hands and I walked home my dad's Knight
now get in here let's make some
spaghetti let's do this right right so
proud of me so now now I just gonna tell
you a couple of these you know number
one that top made life will give you
what you'll fight for that's really the
point of the story now my mother who
heard me tell this story one of the
times she feels like I should also
divulge another set of facts I don't
even know why this is relevant at all
but because my mom asked you I will just
because this was the I just tell you I
was seven Ray Ray was four I just want
you to know that but I don't know why
that's even relevant why is that
relevant
for real
that's true little seven-year-old
kicking a four-year-old's but with
noogies in the driveway but hey listen
to me you all got some RayRay's in your
life stuff you make much bigger and more
difficult and more powerful than it is
that could defeat you in hindsight I was
dammed seven years old this kid was
practically in diapers still of course I
could kick his butt right so hey maybe
you could relate to that you got
something you like like that all right
mom you see this on youtube I did tell
the truth this time so just so you know
I've got a special bonus cup from Edie
on how to not hold yourself back that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what problem can you
leverage to grow number two who can you
recognize in your life to say thank you
and number three where do you need to
get laser focused and I hope everybody
listed this we all have things in our
life listen listen we all have things in
our life were ashamed of it's right we
all I was just thinking of something the
other day I'm real didn't inches at AMA
but I can't believe I did that at one
age I had done something in a classroom
on a test in college you know nothing I
can't believe I did that like I think we
all do things were ashamed of and what
happens is is we hold our own sins
against ourselves and for the rest of
our life and they hold us back from
making progress
if you want more admire let Chuck at the
top fifty rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the comfortable road will never lead you
to the person you were destined to be
ever in your life I'm constantly in a
crisis to get to the next version of